let me tell you a story a hog got here
for eighteen year old I go from being
sitting in classrooms and Mae graduating
high school to being a multi-millionaire
a month later you know you hear the
saying like you changed like damn right
of course I changed I'm trying to better
myself I haven't you chain need
motivation watch it upended believe me
what's that belief nation at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and join today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up with
a single mom in a tough environment and
moving in with a local youth football
coach who introduced him to basketball
at age 9 to becoming one of the greatest
basketball players of all time
he's LeBron James and here's my take on
his top 10 rules a success vol 2 joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make sacrifices
[Music]
let's not create LeBrons legacy let him
free one for himself
let me tell you a story a hog got here
started off in my hometown and back in
Ohio come from a single-parent household
my mother Gloria James was 16 years old
when she had me never met my father so
right then and there he knew it was
gonna be some type of struggle you know
but for me my mother is my rock my
mother is my everything my mom said the
standard of what it means to actually
sacrifice no you move along too when I
started playing sports our home town I
feel like was the shield around me I
knew the city itself I knew the ground
itself the concrete that I walked on the
streets that I went on the streetlights
that looked after me when it was time to
go in the house and I stayed out later
past that they all took care of me you
know to get to this point today I think
the number one thing that you got to
understand it's gonna be sacrifice it's
never gonna be a time of your life where
you're gonna ever be able to say like I
did this alone
nobody has ever got to the top of the
mountain early on
I just always kind of just count my
blessings you know every single day from
the time I was put into a family that I
had known before me when I was 10 years
old and I think the Walker family every
single day because they helped change my
life my AAU coach coach Dru Joyce you
know showing me what family is all about
having a family being married you know
having kids and you know and working up
in a real job but also sacrificing his
time and his commitment for us as kids
to my high school coach and coach
damrell he showed me what it meant to
actually work streams artichoke crash
because when you work extremely hard you
get you know you get something out of it
[Applause]
LeBron James sizes up for Ziggy's
step-back three
take it away
rule number two no you're worth being
like a first generational moneymaker in
the household is a scary thing and for
18 year old I go from being sitting in
classrooms and may graduating high
school to being a multimeter near a
month later for me it was like holy now
we're in this room and it's real it's
not like I had that moment we were
sitting in that room at Reebok and Paul
fireman was very smart he said to you
you know I know you're gonna go see Nike
and Adidas but I'm gonna offer you ten
million dollars today if you don't go
see them to shake my hand
he offered he brought you a ten million
dollar check in that room and you turned
it down I can't say I would have turned
to done I mean I think in the room I
said yeah let's take this check and get
the hell out of here
but you turned it down was it see what
was that thinking with you do you
remember what I was thinking of why you
did it well I mean I remember first of
all the one of the longest damp tables
adversely my longest table but longest
ballroom tables ever seen in my life and
I had no idea what he was doing at the
other end of the table I just seen him
right yeah and he was talking his head
down he was making sure he didn't get
anything wrong on that on that check and
when he slid it down there and he said
listen if you take this right now you
know you just promise me you won't go
talk to Nike or adidas you know you can
take this right now and and I was I was
lost for words at the beginning I mean
if we flew in I flew in from Akron Ohio
that spring here in the projects on the
projects I mean I written is like 17
dollars a month exactly now I'm looking
at a 10 million dollar check that you
can leave with it yeah and go to high
school and go back to the classroom the
next day I was you were going to
homeroom the next one was going a whole
room the next morning saw like holy SH
that's my first initial thing and then I
for some odd reason I started thinking
like if this guy which is a he's a great
guy to still love him to this day he's
unbelievable guy
but if he's willing to give me a ten
million dollar check right now what does
this say that Nike or adidas is not
willing to give me 20 or 30 you know
upfront you know or to say that maybe
the upfront money is not even the
biggest thing you know maybe let's start
thinking about the back again you know
and you know I've always you know and
that comes from you know my uncles as
well just you know never put all your
eggs in one basket you know and give
give it an opportunity to give people an
opportunity to say what they what they
got to pitch themselves and you know we
all we always say that I said we're
gonna hear all three companies we want
to hear all three companies what they
have to say
you know what's they're playing and I
can't I still can't believe I left that
team I can't believe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
- 60
James solo bishop rule number three do
what makes you happy you guys don't get
any breaks how do you learn to deal with
that just tell exactly everybody's not
gonna like what you do everybody's not
gonna like what you said you know but
when you when you're passionate about it
and you stand you stand by it then you
can you can sleep better at night I mean
for us all three of us you know not just
me and Katie but you as well Carrie we
when you work as hard as we do and we
commit to what we do you do two things
do you inspire the people that want to
be you or even better car and then for
us individually you got to do what makes
you happy you got to do what makes you
happy you got to get to a point where
it's like people are gonna they're gonna
they're gonna like it they're gonna
dislike you know at this point now with
social media ain't number two double tap
what we look like or dislike to your
college player
you
[Applause]
rule number four don't sell yourself
short now I feel like the odds against
us you know from it from the summer we
just had so many things going with our
team we shuffled in different lineups we
shuffled in different players we made a
trade at the day line and I can't see
here right now I say that that that the
finals was was a part of my thinking it
was not even when you saw me at one
point early in the season I think it was
in December or January and you just
looked at me like okay well now I know
you what you what you're doing and it's
crazy because right before you see me I
had already kind of hit that switch I
was like okay I'm not quite sure what
we're gonna do with this ball club
we're not playing good basketball but
you can't sell yourself short but to see
I can't even lie to you seer and Sam
would be a part of the finals I would be
definitely lying to you if I said yes we
would be in the finals in January
February yeah you didn't think that that
was the case I don't
it was that point where it was like okay
we're the Cavs even make the playoffs
you know and I was okay I'm not settling
for that conversation no that's just
that's ridiculous I got to get into the
postseason and I've always said if I get
into the postseason no matter if I'm a 1
seed or a seed or in this case a 4 seed
I believe that we can we can do
something and look at it we did
something we did something
Wow
rule number five be careful with your
finances you know my uncle's always
taught me like they was my savings
account they taught me how to have a
savings account so you know if they give
me a dollar they'd be like listen nephew
you know going to spend 35 cent of it
and keep the other 65 you know if they
gave me $2 it like you know go ahead and
spend a dollar of it but stash the other
dollar so I'm always in my head about
stashing and like keeping my money like
you know sacred and to myself because I
didn't know when the next I didn't know
what my uncle was gonna give me another
dollar here or another 50 cent here so
I've always kind of had dad like that
that closure about my finances and
things of that nature
[Applause]
23:22 will
the star few trips into our trench the
Cavaliers get the job done with the left
hand no less rule number six get better
every day you grow up enough in the
african-american community it's like
everyone is so happy when we all on the
same level exactly and as soon as you
they would become a little successful
with anything in life even as a kid even
as a 14 year old 15 year old people envy
that happen it's really interesting to
watch you to mature and change over the
years but it's a part of the process you
know you hear the saying like you
changed like you're damn right
of course I've changed I'm trying to
better myself I haven't you changed and
that's and things that you have to deal
with even as a kid growing up playing
ball
[Music]
[Applause]
great memory to make a pass like that
LeBron James away for the weigh-in rule
number seven come through on your word
we were able to come through on your
word it allows the guys that you're
leading male or female to be able to say
okay we can follow this person because
he won't let us down you know for me as
the leader of our franchise and the
leader of my household and a leader of
so many you know different different
things I think it's the confidence but
it's also you practicing what you preach
I'm not a guy who just talks about I
actually go out and do it as well from a
basketball perspective or from from a
leadership perspective or my kids in my
foundation you know we have a promise
initiative where they promised me that
they will go to school there with city
teachers they'd be great to their
classmates and I promise them that I
will continue to be a great role model a
father figure for them and not let those
guys down so I'll take that
responsibility and I don't just talk
about I actually do it as well so when
you're able to come through on your word
it allows the guys that you're leading
male or female to be able to say okay we
can follow this person because he won't
let us down no matter if it's no matter
if it's going good or bad you know every
day is not a bed of roses we understand
that and you have to be able to handle
adversity as well
retailer
14 Kevlar [ __ ]
[Applause]
rule number eight my personal favorite
believe in your product we both invested
in blaze
it's obviously done very well but you
had a great contract with McDonald's
yeah that was set to pay you I mean
you're another fourteen or fifteen
million dollars left guaranteed and I
came to you with the idea that hey I
think you let let's get rid of
McDonald's you'll give away that money
you won't make that money but there's a
better investment I think we can invest
in this thing that a better fits where
you're going as a person your lifestyle
and B I think it's a better business
idea what what is it about that that you
went I'm okay I trust that I believe in
that let's do that I believed in to the
actual product first and and like I said
was a great partnership with McDonald's
we had we had a great time we did some
great things on television and we did
some great things over the years but I
remember we went the UC Irvine it's the
first-ever Blazers every place and we
tasted the product and the product was
phenomenal you know and I actually took
a PI back back to the hotel as well and
then you came with me with the
proposition that we could actually own
our own and be franchisees of a couple
cities in America and the numbers that
you were showing me did the potential
that we could make if we just put the
time and effort into it exceeded you
know what McDonald's would be
guaranteeing me for over the next four
years but more importantly I think for
me it was like oh wow we get to actually
build this you be a part of speaking a
part of something I so get the money and
you forget the money we can actually
build something and and if it doesn't
become successful then I can only blame
myself because I know the product is
that damn good
and it goes tops his legs
rule number nine follow your dreams I
had dreams man every single day every
single day I had a dream of being
something special did I know it's gonna
be an NBA player I didn't but I
definitely dreamed about every single
day and I just give all thanks to the
man of all first of all for giving me
everything and I give all the credit to
everybody else that was been arriving my
whole support system from my city to my
family to my friends I'm happy that I
could see in front of you today I'm
being an inspiration to you and inspire
you to want to be as great as you want
to be it's just a lie on that the small
kid in the small city where big dreams
and big heart are you able to wrap your
mind around that and push forward and
play school I think it becomes
unbreakable nobody can ever stop
digit she puts it home
everybody even myself included thought
that ball was going to kyle korver right
there for easy three he is holding the
basketball like it's a football and it
might be a quarterback watch the ball
fake and that the little lead to zeus it
pretty look left oh he's at the park
right there he's got two playing around
easy and rule number 10 the last home
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun Sunday LeBron James yes we didn't
weekend whoopsies just get popped with a
call that's second basketball coming out
of nowhere now looks like that
volleyball move where dodgeball you lob
one and the Chuck's been reduced to
unsuccessfully I might add
well Kyrie Irving just missed here goes
James and nope
[Applause]
[Music]
what's rolling along for you oh just
being aggressive and I'm doing what I
normally doing as a you know take high
percentage shots say oh you're just
decide stuff LeBron tosses a towel right
onto the head of Kevin Love yeah I don't
do that to a GQ model have a lot of
great reaction painting the sweat of
LeBron yeah doesn't really enjoy I like
that LeBron actually feel bad yeah look
at that brotherly live scene he loves he
loves Kevin Love just like you love
Chris Bosh oh excuse me are you get off
the floor LeBron James to play anybody
called decides I got better dance at it
yeah so I don't get a technical very
great step alright moonwalk Brumbies
well clearly to to the second lesson
highest paid Shirley in Northeast Ohio
oh you're gonna love it because all this
is gonna do a seat
Green looking to the front for here's
LeBron James
[Applause]
shades of 2009 it gifts your landing
now I've got a really special a Braun
James clip on how to think long term
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know which
message resonated more with you think
long term or make sacrifices let me know
leaving the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
throughout this journey of mine of just
like you know we also about the process
you know in the process of me trying to
become the greatest of all time or
maximize you know my potential as a
player I also have to be able once I'll
leave battle or leave competition that
have to accept the fact that there's
certain things that I'm maybe don't know
or don't know enough of so I have to ask
questions you know it's a challenging
thing but at the same time I know that
once I get off the floor there's gonna
be more time of my life spin off the
floor then on the floor it's a good way
to look exact so from age 9 to if you
make it to 40 if you make it to 40
that's 31 years of your life but from 40
to 85 90 hopefully I'm lucky to get to
90 that's 50 years so you know I still
have to live life you know beyond the
hardwood if you tell yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
don't you believe you act like I am
Tulsa what a whale out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I've
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access